ja da sind wir sehr gespannt und wir
vorne sind wir gespannt auf das was die
fünf sagen wie sich jetzt aufgebaut
haben und es beginnt der kanzlerkandidat
und im bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz
meine damen und herren wir haben heute
im präsidium noch einmal sehr sorgfältig
über den gestrigen wahltag gesprochen
und seine konsequenzen für uns ist ganz
klar dass daraus ein auftrag abgeleitet
werden muss dass wir jetzt uns bemühen
eine regierung zu bilden eine regierung
getragen von den parteien die die wahl
gewonnen haben das ist die spd mit einem
sehr erheblichen zuwachs an stimmen das
sind die grünen und das ist die fdp und
wir werden deshalb auch mit allen
versuchen gemeinsam diesen weg zu
beschreiten
es hat in deutschland eine sehr
erfolgreiche sozial-liberale koalition
gegeben von 1969 bis 82 übrigens damals
aus einer großen koalition heraus wenn
man das noch erinnern darf und wie die
brand ist dann 69 kanzler geworden
helmut schmidt meistern den zweiten teil
dieser zeit und wir haben eine sehr gute
regierungszeit mit dem grünen gehabt und
auch das ist eine sache die wir uns noch
gut erinnern jetzt gewissermaßen eine
sozial-ökologische liberale koalition zu
bilden hat also
grundlagen in der geschichte der
regierungstätigkeit in deutschland und
ist auch genau das was man tun muss wenn
man jetzt dafür sorgen will dass in
deutschland die zukunftsaufgaben
aufgegriffen werden die vor uns stehen
dazu zählt also zum beispiel dafür zu
sorgen dass wir mehr respekt in dieser
gesellschaft haben dass wir die
industrielle modernisierung dieses
landes hinbekommen und den menschen
gemacht und dieser wandel aufhalten
große aufgaben denen wir uns stellen
wollen und über die wir gerne mit den
beiden anderen parteien ins gespräch
kommen wollen um dann so schnell wie
möglich auch tatsächlich eine regierung
zu bilden
das werden wir den gremien empfehlen im
übrigen haben wir noch mal gesehen dass
die erfolge in mecklenburg-vorpommern
und in berlin eben doch auch das noch
mal zusätzlich unterstreichen dass wir
hier gesehen haben am wahltag die
bürgerinnen und bürger wünschen sich ein
regierungswechsel und sie wollen auch
dass wir
die regierung führen in deutschland in
berlin und in mecklenburg vorpommern
wenn man sich die ergebnisse insgesamt
noch einmal anschaut dann sieht man
übrigens dass wir in vielen ländern dazu
gewonnen haben dass die spd auch in der
bevölkerungsreichen ländern stärkste
partei geworden ist bei den mandaten und
war den zweitstimmen etwas ganz ganz
besonderes und insofern fühlen wir uns
gesondert aufgerufen jetzt aus dem
auftrag den die wlan und wähler uns
gegeben haben sehr bescheiden und mit
großer professionalität und ganz
pragmatisch ein gutes ergebnis zu machen
alle parteien die hier erfolge bei der
wahl hatten sind parteien die schon
miteinander regiert haben in der
geschichte die es gegenwärtig tun in
einzelnen bundesländern und klar ist
auch dass niemand an dem votum der
wähler novelle ohne schaden vorbeigehen
kann und das ist schon sehr deutlich
dass viele sich wünschen dass wir diese
nächste regierung bilden wir freuen uns
auf ihre zahlreichen fragen
morgen jetzt stolz die frage ist ansieht
wie er spricht von der neuen osnabrücker
zeitung herr scholz was sagen sie dazu
dass die grünen und die fdp jetzt erst
einmal untereinander sprechen möchten
und wenn sie noch eine persönliche frage
erlauben wie lange haben sie heute nach
geschlafen und was war ihr erster
gedanke beim aufwachen danke
erstmal ist es völlig okay wenn auch
diejenigen mit denen wir
zusammenarbeiten wollen untereinander
sprechen ich möchte eine regierung
bilden die auf vertrauen droht der
parteien untereinander
das muss ja darum gehen dass man nicht
nur die aufgaben bewältigt über die man
sich in einem koalitionsvertrag
verständigt sondern auch die vielen
aufgaben die auf einen zukommen die man
am anfang gar nicht erkennen kann auch
die letzten jahre der regierung waren
immer davon geprägt dass wir neue dinge
zu bewältigen hatten die sich nicht
abgezeichnet hatten während der
koalitionsbildung insofern geht es schon
darum dass das gut läuft ich finde es
gibt auch einen grundsatz der ganz
wichtiges regierungsparteien müssen
einander vertrauen sie müssen
miteinander zusammenarbeiten wollen und
nicht gewissermaßen immer hinten herum
erzählen was die anderen alles schlecht
machen die schwarz-gelbe koalition ist
sicherlich in den letzten jahren das
abschreckende beispiel für
regierungstätigkeit gewesen weil das
vertrauen zwischen cdu csu und fdp
überhaupt nicht existiert hat ich glaube
daran erinnern sich auch viele in der
fdp noch sehr genau wie schlecht das
auch für sie von seiten der cdu csu
damals gelaufen ist und deshalb sollte
es hier ganz anders sein ich finde eine
regierung die sich gebildet hat muss
auch so miteinander regieren dass sie
sich zutraut auch wiedergewählt zu
werden auch das wäre für mich ein guter
grundsatz
ansonsten habe ich gut geschlafen und
ich bin aufgewacht hat noch mal geguckt
ob irgendwas passiert ist was sich beim
einschlafen nicht zur kenntnis nehmen
konnte und habe mich dann noch mal
gefreut
ja mein name ist zuckowski ich bin von
der finnischen zeitung helsingin sanomat
im europäischen ausland interessiert man
sich unter anderem dafür wie die nächste
deutsche regierung was was die nächste
deutsche regierung vom gemeinsamen
schulden hält nun bei manchen
sogenannten sparsamen mit riesen dann
hat man sogar angst von der sogenannten
schuldenunion was ist nun ihre position
jetzt noch der bundestagswahl als
möglicher nächster konnte
ich glaube dass die sozialdemokratischen
regierungschef innen und der
regierungschef in den skandinavischen
ländern und der künftige regierungschef
in norwegen das ist sich alle freuen
darüber dass die spd diese wahl gewonnen
hat jedenfalls ist das was ich von allen
als botschaft bekommen habe vielleicht
noch einmal zu einer aussage zur frage
wie geht es da weiter wir haben eine
große kraftanstrengung unternommen um
die krise zu bekämpfen in europa das
haben wir gemeinsam getan nun ist ja
bisher noch nicht so viel geld geflossen
außer für die ersten maßnahmen die für
diskus arbeiter programm in europa auf
den weg gebracht haben und für die
mittelstands kredite der europäischen
investitionsbank
sondern die mittel für den wiederaufbau
form sind ja im wesentlichen in aussicht
gestellt aber allein die tatsache dass
wir das gemacht haben dazu beigetragen
dass sich die konjunktur in europa
erholt dass kein staat schwierigkeit mit
seiner staatsfinanzierung bekommen hat
schon etwas ganz ganz besonderes
trotzdem gehört zu den verständigung die
wir dort getroffen haben erstens die
union nimmt dafür kredite auf zweitens
sie werden zurückgezahlt bis 2058 darauf
habe ich bestanden dass das auch
festgelegt und wann es wird und wann es
spätestens beginnt und drittens zur
finanzierung werden wir auch kopien
resources schaffen also ich glaube
die skandinavischen länder werden sehr
glücklich sein über das was wir
miteinander machen in europa es geht um
starkes souveränes europa in einer welt
die nicht einfacher wird
im raume von der rheinischen post herr
scholz werden sie in den
koalitionsverhandlungen
punkte nennen die für die spd und für
sie persönlich unverhandelbar sind oder
sagen sie wir gegen ergebnisoffen dort
hinein
und stellen alles als verhandlungsmasse
ein und frau gefahr eine frage an sie
bitte sie könnten ja jetzt mit einer
ampel in berlin eine gute vorlage für
ihren kanzlerkandidaten liefern wie
stehen sie denn zu diesem projekt
die spd hat ein programm aufgestellt das
kann jeder lesen wir alle haben das auf
vielen marktplätzen in deutschland an
vielen infoständen bei vielen haustür
besuchen vertreten und das will ich noch
mal sagen das hat ja zu diesem ergebnis
geführt dass wir da stehen wo wir jetzt
stehen ist ein gemeinsames ergebnis der
ganzen spd und sind alle 400.000
mitglieder aktiv gewesen aber es hat
auch eine wirklich gute und
funktionierende zusammenarbeit gegeben
in der ganzen führung die beiden
parteivorsitzenden der generalsekretär
der fraktions position ich haben uns
engst abgestimmt schon lange bevor sie
wussten dass sich der kanzlerkandidat
werde wussten wir das miteinander und
das ist ein zeichen dafür wie gut das
funktioniert hat und die bürgerinnen
bürger haben jetzt weit über ein jahr
gesehen dass das geklappt hat und können
sich darauf verlassen dass dieses
gemeinsame management einer so großen
aufgabe für eine so traditionsreiche
demokratische partei und im hinblick auf
die anforderungen die wir in
verantwortung für unser land zu erfüllen
haben auch in zukunft gut klappen wird
aber dazu gehört auch dass wir jetzt
koalitionsverhandlungen nicht in der
öffentlichkeit führen ich glaube es
gehört zu den guten stil dass man nicht
in lauter durch gesteckten papieren
lesen kann was gewissermaßen der eine
von dem anderen denkt sondern dass es
wirklich vertrauensvoll zur kooperation
kommt ich halte also nichts davon und
wir alle darauf war haben wir uns
verständigt dass wir jetzt irgendwie
einzelne punkte mit ihnen sorgfältig
durch diskutieren das machen wir mit den
freunden mit denen wir regieren wollen
in berlin kann ich mich da anschließen
es ist so dass wir verschiedene
möglichkeiten haben für eine koalition
hier in der hauptstadt definitiv würde
die koalition unter sozialdemokratischer
führung arbeiten und wir werden in den
gremien besprechen was funktionieren
kann wie wir die möglichst großen
schnittmengen haben mit dem programm das
wir als sozialdemokraten in berlin
beschlossen haben und natürlich kann
eine möglichkeit die im bund erfolgreich
ist die übrigens auch in rheinland-pfalz
er erfolgreich ist auch ein weg für
berlin sein aber nochmal wir müssen das
in den gremien besprechen und wir werden
mit allen gespräche führen und dann den
besten weg für die stadt auch ausloten
frage an sehr stolz wie groß ist denn
ihre erleichterung darüber dass ein
linksbündnis aufgrund der schwäche der
linkspartei überhaupt nicht mehr möglich
ist es gab ja doch einige in der spd
sich die sich das gewünscht hätten es
gibt nun auch befürchtungen dass
christian lindner die preise hochtreiben
könnte weil eben die drohkulisse
linksbündnis nicht mehr steht und
vielleicht eine zweite frage an sie oder
auch an herrn walter borjans
verhandlungen mit der fdp steuerpolitik
ist das für sie der größte brocken ist
das die größte schwierigkeit wo man sich
annähern muss
ja vielleicht darf ich kurz sagen
nämlich auf die inhaltlichen punkte gilt
das was ich eben schon gesagt hat für
uns alle gemeinsam
wir werden jetzt nicht mit ihnen die
einzelne details künftiger
koalitionsgespräche durch erörtern
verstehe dass sie alles genau verstehen
wollen aber wir wollen vertrauensvoll
mit denen reden mit denen wir uns
zusammentun wollen und was das
wahlergebnis betrifft haben wir immer
vor der wahl gesagt das macht gar keinen
sinn
spekulationen darüber anzustellen was
nach der wahl möglich sein wird denn es
ist demokratie die bürgerinnen und
bürger entscheiden sie beschließen auch
mit dem gewicht den dass sie den
einzelnen parteien geben welche
regierungen möglich sind und welcher
auftrag daraus erwächst und der auftrag
den wir bekommen haben von den wählern
und wlan und er ist sehr eindeutig eine
regierung zusammen mit grünen und fdp zu
bilden und das wollen wir jetzt auch
ich will vielleicht noch dazu sagen dass
in der gegenwärtigen situation olaf
scholz hat das gesagt vertrauen
das wichtigste ist um wirklich in einer
regierungskoalition zusammen zu kommen
die auch bestand haben soll und deswegen
finde ich das von allen seiten rote
linien die über die medien dem anderen
zugespielt werden ein kleines fenster
schließen dass für eine gemeinsame
grundlage wichtig wäre und deswegen
finde ich wir sind alle gut beraten das
gilt aber dann für alle seiten dass wir
aufeinander zugehen und ausloten was für
dieses land wichtig ist und das ist vor
allem dass es ein aufbruch gibt der
gerecht ist aber der eben auch kräfte
freisetzt und ich glaube da gibt es eine
ganze reihe von punkten über die man
sehr konstruktiv miteinander reden kann
das vom britischen fernsehen und von mir
eine frage auf englisch gestatten
belasten
sex
ist
nicht mehr aus zu der second klassischen
first the movement of labour ist part of
the pin linien rb workwear i heard
convince the british motto lief die
jungen
[Musik]
athleten
er baut
first mai die
sbb barry forstern getting a result of
government and eight people for
christmas is possible and
usage germany only skin governments and
stable
[Musik]
demokratien in der position
ausnahmsweise mit einer frage auf
deutsch
herr scholz können sie uns ein bisschen
was verraten zu den formaten in denen
sie mit den anderen parteien sprechen
möchten also zum einen wie schnell soll
das passieren inwiefern erstmal auch
bilateral oder eben gleich mit einreihen
und wie groß sollten verhandlungsgruppen
sein wir werden sehr schnell mit den
anderen parteien mit denen wir eine
regierung bilden wollen
uns abstimmen über gesprächs verläufe
ich glaube dass es sondierungen nicht zu
lange geben sollte sondern dass man ab
was sich schnell
einmal
spricht und dann auch eine entscheidung
trifft und dann auch richtig in
koalitionsverhandlungen geht die dann
auch zu ergebnissen führen ich
jedenfalls
glaube dass man sah ich habe jedenfalls
hat mir immer mühe gegeben verhandlungen
so zu führen dass man auch ergebnisse
erzielt die funktionieren für alle drei
parteien für die anhängerschaften und in
diesem fall auch für das land das muss
man immer dazu sagen denn jede partei
hat ja erwartungen die viele menschen
mit ihrer stimmabgabe für diese partei
verbinden geweckt und das muss ja zu
einem guten ergebnis geführt werden wo
alle anhängerschaften sagen das gefällt
mir dass es gut dass sie das gemacht
haben und das will ich noch versuchen
hinzukriegen
wie sega rtl n tv eine frage an frau
gefiel wie bewerten sie denn den ausgang
des berliner volksentscheids zum thema
deutsche wohn enteignen und wie gedenken
sie sich diesem votum dann in zukunft zu
stellen ich habe mich ja im wahlkampf
sehr klar positioniert dass sich
enteignung oder vergesellschaftung nicht
für den richtigen weg halte um die frage
des bezahlbaren wohnens zu lösen wir
haben dennoch jetzt einen volksentscheid
der positiv ausgegangen ist wir müssen
als politik damit verantwortungsvoll und
respektvoll umgehen dass die schritte
die jetzt einzuleiten sind müssen
eingeleitet werden aber ich finde es
muss eine sehr ernsthafte prüfung geben
über rechtmäßigkeit verfassungsmäßigkeit
finanzierbarkeit und die folgen die das
für das land berlin auch hat und in
dieser abwägung müssen wir am ende
entscheiden was wirklich getan werden
kann um mit diesem appell ist es ja
keinen gesetzentwurf sondern ein appell
an die politik umzugehen ich glaube
wesentlich ist dass wir das tun was
nötig ist um das problem zu lösen und
das wohnungsneubau es ist ganz klar der
schutz der mieterinnen und mieter im
bestand aber wir haben in berlin das
ziel im jahr 20.000 wohnungen zu bauen
natürlich auch bezahlbaren wohnraum das
entspricht auch dem was natürlich olaf
scholz sich auf bundesebene vorgenommen
hat wir müssen die große soziale frage
des bezahlbares wohnen wohnens lösen und
das heißt wohnungsneubau in
größenordnung und ein starkes bündnis
zwischen den städtischen gesellschaften
den genossenschaften aber auch den
privaten nur dann werden wir das
hinbekommen
zwei fragen einer an herrn schulz und
einer an herrn walter borjans schulz
armin laschet hat gerade im ruf der cdu
bekanntgegeben dass er gestern bereits
mit christian lindner gesprochen hat und
das heute mit annalena baerbock tun wird
gibt es dazu auch pläne auf seiten der
spd was gespräche angeht und an herrn
beider borjans sie sagten gerade rote
linien können störend sein heißt dass
man es auch bereit zugeständnisse zu
machen gerade auch gegenüber vielleicht
der fdp
also ich bin nicht mitglied des
bundesvorstands der union das weiß ich
nicht was da stattfindet aber einige von
ihnen sind ja embedded wie ich so
mitkriege wenn ich den ticker meldungen
folgen darf unabhängig davon natürlich
gibt es kontakte und im übrigen werden
wir das jetzt ja auch nach den
beschlüssen die wir jetzt geführt haben
ganz formal auch konkret betreiben es
geht darum den wunsch der wähler
umzusetzen und das werden wir mit aller
ruhe und klarheit vorantreiben und ich
glaube dass auch alle verstehen dass da
eine botschaft mit der wahl und dem
wahltag verbunden ist die man nicht
überhören darf
ja ich glaube die das wahlergebnis
gestern abend hat eines ganz deutlich
gemacht es gibt nur eine konstellation
von gewinnern die die künftige regierung
bilden können und das ist
die ampel oder wie wir sagen auch die
rheinland- pfalz lösung und aus diesem
grund finde ich muss klar sein dass man
sich an einen tisch setzt dass man auf
augenhöhe miteinander verhandelt die spd
hat als stärkste kraft in dieser
konstellation den auftrag zur regierung
die stimmung und die stimmen waren einen
deutlich stimmen für einen kanzler olaf
scholz und auf der grundlage sprechen
miteinander untersucht man natürlich die
gemeinsamkeit und die besteht nicht
darin dass man als erstes erstmal alles
von anderen ausschließt und sich damit
anschließend wieder verabschiedet also
wir haben den festen willen eine stabile
auf vertrauen gegründete regierung zu
bilden der die eindeutig als
wahlgewinner aus dieser wahl
hervorgegangen sind
die frage anja scholz erstmal herzlichen
glückwunsch zu ihrem wahlergebnis die
frage stelle ich so wie stellen sie sich
vor in die zukunft die
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit mit
russland und der ukraine
ich komme von russischsprachigen fenster
sind aus berlin deswegen die frage
die zukunft europas wird auch davon
geprägt werden dass es eine gelingt eine
gute zusammenarbeit zwischen der
europäischen
union und ihren nachbarn dann ländern
zustande zu bringen dazu gehört im
übrigen aber dass alle gut akzeptieren
dass es den weiteren fortschritt der
integration der europäischen union gibt
einer gesellschaft mit
freiheitsrechten mit liberalität eine
offene gesellschaft mit marktwirtschaft
und sozialstaatlichen traditionen und
ich glaube das ist dann die grundlage
dafür dass das gelingt in europa das die
voraussetzung dafür immer auch bedeuten
dass wir die kriterien die wir über
gemeinsame sicherheit in europa gefunden
haben ganz in der tradition von willy
brandt und helmut schmidt auch in
zukunft beachtet werden müssen ist klar
eine der ganz wichtigen sachen für gute
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit ist immer
die anerkennung der unverletzlichkeit
der grenzen das gehörte zu den damaligen
prozessen von ksc und osze dazu und das
muss auch heute bestand haben
herr scholz gibt es bereits einen
vorschlag für den spd fraktionsvorsitz
im präsidium oder im vorstand besprochen
worden wäre die es die cdu die union hat
das jahr vertagt vertrag die spd auch
die entscheidung erst mal und die zweite
frage es gab vor der wahl bereits
bestrebungen einen mitgliederentscheid
über einen eventuellen koalitionsvertrag
herbeizuführen wie stehen sie dazu also
wir haben einen formalen vorschlag noch
nicht gemacht aber wir sind uns alle
einig dass der jetzige
fraktionsvorsitzende ein ganz toller
mann ist und ich glaube dass sie nein
der fraktion auch alle so rolf mützenich
ist ein ausstand ein ganz wichtiger
baustein für unser gemeinsames gebäude
gewesen und ohne ihnen hätten die
parteivorsitzende und ich der
generalsekretär das gar nicht geschafft
diese große linie über so lange zeit zu
entwickeln also ein guter mann und den
brauchen wir da und die zweite frage ist
wir werden jetzt erst mal gespräche
führen und alle anderen entscheidungen
treffen wir wenn es soweit ist
in st
meine
ja hallo jan dörner stücke der zeitung
die beiden frauen fressen fressen wie
sehen sie denn jetzt die aussichten
zusammen mit der fdp und den grünen zu
reagieren regieren
können sie sich das gut vorstellen
sie haben im wahlkampf immer von einer
progressiven regierung gesprochen die
gebildet werden soll könnte die ampel
das sein
der progressive regierung wie ich sie
mir vorstelle die markiert tatsächlich
einen aufbruch für deutschland ich
glaube dass wir auch in der zeit stehen
diesen aufbruch verlangt in vielen
fragen im bewältigen des klimawandels in
der gestaltung der digitalisierung und
vielen anderen fragen die werden unserem
zukunftsprogramm aufgeschrieben haben
muss nach vorne gehen und das war immer
meine überzeugung dass wir dazu auch
parteien brauchen die sich zum einen
vertrauen die zum anderen aber auch
einen auftrag von wählerinnen und
wählern haben wir haben jetzt drei
parteien es ist schon gesagt worden die
gestern einen zugewinn verbuchen konnten
die spd steht mit ihrem zu gewinnen ganz
vorne und wir freuen uns sehr auf die
zusammenarbeit und auf die gespräche die
jetzt anstehen
ich bin auf sesseln technischer fällen
seien
besser prinzip an für sie wichtig sind
dahin außenpolitik in
koalitionsverhandlungen und
möchten sie das seines films 2 mit der
arbeit beginnt
für die außenpolitik deutschlands gilt
auf alle fälle das für uns ein
gemeinsames handeln der europäischen
union
die grundlage für all das ist was wir in
den nächsten jahren tun müssen die welt
wird bald zehn milliarden einwohner
haben es wird viele mächte geben nicht
nur die usa china und russland sondern
auch andere länder das wieder
aufgestiegenen asiens korea japan
vietnam indonesien malaysia indien um
einige zu nennen das wird auch starke
länder aus afrika oder dem süden
amerikas geben die in 20 30 jahren
relevant sein werden der welt und wenn
wir das was uns wichtig ist ein
rechtsstaat demokratie marktwirtschaft
und sozialstaat auch an technologischer
fortschrittlichkeit sichern wollen dann
gibt es nur gemeinsam in der
europäischen union und die ist deshalb
immer ein wichtiges datum darum glaube
ich auch dass deutschland eine besondere
herausforderung hat als das große land
mitten in der europäischen union mit
seiner großen bevölkerung und seiner
großen wirtschaftskraft es zur eigenen
nationalen sache zu machen dass der
fortschritt der europäischen union
gelingt dass es eine gute kooperation
gibt zwischen ost und west in der eu
zwischen nord und süd dass niemand
versucht die union zu dominieren sondern
dass das eine gemeinsame gute
perspektive wird dazu gehört auch dass
wir politisch relevant sein müssen wo
die bürger um bürger politische relevanz
verlangen und wir sollten all denjenigen
widerstehen die von uns herum oder sind
ganz schön viele versuchung
zurückzukehren in die zeiten des 17 18
19 jahrhunderts mit der idee als ob man
direkt was macht mit den großen ländern
europas deutschland frankreich england
und russland und alle anderen gucken zu
nein das was wir als fortschritt
erreicht haben ist dass die europäische
union zusammen wächst und wir werden
dafür sorgen dass sie eine bessere union
wird das ist ein wichtiges merkmal für
die politik die ich mir für die zukunft
vorgestellt habe und was die frage
dieses gas
pipeline projekt betrifft das ist ja nun
fertiggestellt und es geht darum dass
jetzt alle dafür sorgen dass die
garantien die mit dem betrieb verbunden
sind auch akzeptiert werden zu den
garantien gehört dass die ukraine
transit land bleibt und dass wir
sicherstellen dass nicht der gast die
gasversorgung einiger länder im osten
europas zb gefährdet wird von russland
aus weil sie sagen dass sie diese
strukturen nicht mehr bedienen wollen
und das ist etwas worauf sich alle
verlassen können das haben wir sehr
ernst gemeint und dafür haben wir uns
auch sehr eingesetzt
die united states in einer station
in
china
will be
made in the
united
states transatlantic partnership ist
office for germany
important that we work together
we do have komplexen banorte kosten
vielleicht darf ich wenn die fragerunde
zu ende ist noch mal sagen was wir
eingangs gesagt haben es gibt gute
tradition auf die wir zurückgreifen
können es hat eine sozialliberale
regierung gegeben rot-gelb es hat eine
sozial-ökologische regierung gegeben rot
grün und wenn wir daran anknüpfen dann
kann etwas gutes gelingen am beginn der
20er jahre für unser land denn das ist
doch etwas sehr bemerkenswert es gibt
drei parteien in deutschland die eine
jeweils eigene fortschritts erzählung
haben die vorstellung wie fortschritt in
deutschland gelingen kann die
sozialdemokratische partei hat eine
solche vorstellung die wir mit unserem
programm nun mit dem wofür wir in der
wahl geworben haben vorgestellt haben
die grünen haben eine da spielt der das
aufhalten des klimawandels genauso wie
bei uns und bei anderen eine rolle aber
es ist dort sehr sehr sehr zentral aber
es ist eine fortschritts erzählung und
eine fortschritts erzählung für eine
moderne gesellschaft gibt es auch bei
der fdp wenn also drei parteien die den
fortschritt am beginn der 20er jahre im
blick haben sich zusammentun dann kann
das etwas gutes werden selbst wenn sie
dafür unterschiedliche ausgangslagen
haben und das konstruktiv zusammen zu
führen das ist das was wir hier
gemeinsam auf den weg bringen wollen und
wo wir ein mandat der bürgerinnen und
bürger sehen das auch ernsthaft
voranzutreiben schönen dank
schuss
ist zu ende oder nicht
da macht man auch
soweit also die pressekonferenz der spd
spitzenkandidaten zur bundestagswahl zur
wahl in
mecklenburg vorpommern und zur wahl hier
in berlin zur abgeordnetenhauswahl und
das ganze hatte ein hauch von
internationalität sie haben es gemerkt
es gab drei frage die ihre fragen an
olaf scholz hier auf englisch gestellt
haben und er hat sie recht souverän
sprachlich betrachtet beantwortet und
ohne mit der wimper zu zucken und
darüber hinaus auch noch mal betont was
aus seiner sicht das bevorzugte
koalitionsmodell sein soll nicht
sonderlich überraschend dass die grünen
mit dabei sind dabei hat auch noch mal
deutlich geworden für gespräche zu einer
ampel-koalition und das begründet unter
anderem damit dass spd grüne aber auch
die fdp zu den drei parteien gehören die
bei dieser wahl jetzt gewonnen haben die
deutlich zugelegt haben und die deshalb
den auftrag von den wählerinnen und
wählern bekommen haben eine regierung zu
bilden